PROFESSOR: Hi.
In this clip, we're going to
discuss the numbering and
labeling conventions of
RNA and of protein.
Here we have a nucleoside
triphosphate or NTP.
This NTP is numbered
on each carbon.
And we're going to start here
to the right of this oxygen
and label one prime and proceed
two prime, three
prime, four prime, and this
last, five prime carbon.
This means that when we
polymerize two or more of
these NTP's to get an RNA chain,
it becomes apparent why
one end is labeled five prime
and the other end is labeled
three prime.
On this end, the extending atom
is the five prime carbon.
And on this side, the other end,
the extending atom is the
three prime carbon attached
to this oxygen.
This three prime carbon is where
you would attach another
NTP if you would wish to
extend this chain.
And so we label the ends of RNA
five prime to three prime.
And RNA is always polymerized in
the five prime to the three
prime direction.
Now with our amino acid, we
label this end, which is our
amino terminus, as N and this
end which is our carboxy
terminus as C. As before, when
we polymerize three amino
acids into this short protein
chain, I'm going to label this
end which has a protruding amino
terminus as N and this
end which has a protruding
carboxy terminus as C.
So that's how the conventions
are in science to label and
number amino acids
and proteins.
Thanks for watching.